[Music]
how are you guys spending your time are
there like is there a balance that's
shifted at all like between work and
play or is it all just all the days
melding together and your whole schedule
is kind of al [ __ ] oh it's a balance
yeah
what's your balance like cuz Monday's
you have one day's our margarita is
Tuesdays our dad out to a schedule but
luckily I still have work so that I have
to wake up I guess certain time to make
sure like I we have a car Skype or
resume conferences and stuff so you keep
yourself on a schedule for Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday like two three oh [ __ ] time to
go to bed for that yeah for four or five
dude don't you feel like you wasted the
day when you sleep in that late no
because first I was like I like waking
up early and they're like if I have to
go trade am i literally for you what's
your you okay but just because literally
nothing will happen and like I'm on top
of the work and I can but that's when it
starts to play blenders actually
starting to get lazy and I'm like what
am I doing with my time I'm literally
just doing nothing you know yeah because
if you sleep eight hours and you still
work the same on our amount of hours
doesn't matter when you go to sleep or
wake up yeah but it's still like even
though it's in in 14-time it's like back
then it's like if you wake up at like
4:00 a.m. you're ahead of everyone
you're doing that like that might up be
ahead of other people which I feel like
I'm lacking but then now I just think of
it as I'm waking up later and I'm
enjoying my time but then it doesn't
it's the same thing so if you sleep at
9:00 p.m. and you wake up at 4 a.m.
right it's the same thing as like sleepy
sunlight though I don't get enough of it
oh yeah that's what I feel like I didn't
feel the same at least not for me it
does like it feels completely different
if I go to bed late and I wake up at the
same time like my whole rhythm and like
I just felt [ __ ] up I felt like super
discombobulated well if you wake up at
early in the morning and you go to sleep
late that means you're sleep-deprived ah
no like if I go to the yeah yeah you
take a nap oh oh I mean even if like I'm
the I only need
six hours of sleep but if I sleep a
little bit later and I wake up early
like I just because your circadian is
all yeah it's like you're jet-lagged
yeah exactly
if I sleep more I feel [ __ ] here that's
part you really I need five hours maybe
six hours and then I can't sleep more I
can't get eight yeah well if I go to
sleep like say like I don't have like
back before 14 we talk about you only
need five or six hours yeah you actually
need it and then you know here's what
happens as he gets five hours of sleep
and I have but then one day he'll sleep
for like 12 hours something like make it
all up seems actually 22 and it looks
like you would yeah you look a lot
younger
no I look I can't sleep fired
I feel lethargic I love it
I wonder I wonder if I actually got a
full eight hours but I feel like my body
functions better with like five or six
and like I have to be up and then it's
fine like I go to see about one and out
to be up at like six or seven to go film
or do whatever and then it's like I feel
good but if I get longer than I wake up
slower I do whatever I feel like I need
to harness whatever sunlight I have
because I feel bad if I wasted most of
my my day so if I wake up late I just
feel bad because I'm like oh she I only
have like six hours of sunlight left I
feel like my brain is like a timer
ticking down until the Sun is going down
so if I wake up late I'm like oh no I
only have this much left in my hourglass
and I'll just feel like the sunlight
hours of productive hours so I'm like
the Sun down I'm like I've run out of
productive hours yeah that's why I hate
when it goes down at like 4:30 like in
the human right where people have their
own natural circadian rhythms circadian
it's kind of like you're your biological
yeah your body knows that it's time to
go to sleep so it starts producing
hormones and things for you like when a
certain time hits or whatever but
there's nocturnal people and there's
there's like morning people so the
morning people they have the best focus
and energy in the morning yeah it's not
all the same and what we found that's
genetically
yeah yeah what people found out or
scientist or whatever is that the reason
why teens a lot of them come off as lazy
too is because their circadian rhythm
isn't like an adult's because they're
still growing and then they they're
about an hour
like off of what everyone else is so
they're still sleepy at a certain time
Kings our SWAT teams teams Kings
circadian rhythm is different it comes
from Joe it's not that all yeah did I
say King Nolan there's been studies that
show that teens actually need more sleep
and in the younger you are you need more
like babies need like 16 hours or
something right or 12 yeah and then you
know lazy has babies suck on a titty and
sleep and then the older you get like I
said you're a senior you need you you
only need like five hours that's what
I've been saying I just don't like it
when I sleep too much I just feel very
sleepy no it's gonna be great when we're
parents cuz then you get to watch the
kids and most of the time cuz I'll just
be sleeping I love my sleep Oh we'll see
haha what I feel like I rediscovered the
80/20 rule do you guys know the Pareto's
law the 80/20 rule okay so like studies
have found that there's this universal
law you could be applied to a lot of
different aspects of life but 80% of
your productivity comes from 20% of the
things you do 80% of the effects of
something come from 20% of the causes
and so getting refreshed on this I
started applying it to my life because
before quarantine I felt like I was so
busy I was constantly busy busy busy
busy I wake up in the morning I start
working I don't stop working until I go
to bed at night I was just constant
there's so much to do there's so much to
do I always just felt like there was
always so much to do I felt like busy
was part of my identity but then after I
was rereading about the Pareto's law and
how like you're really like 80% of the
things I'm doing or only causing 20% of
the productivity
so I started only focusing on the 20% of
things that I do that are causing the
most like that are making the most money
that are making that giving me the most
joy that are doing like giving me the
most out of life and so now I don't work
at all now you have that 80% of your
time to commit to animal causing that's
great yeah without feeling bad so chill
like I just
ress monster before but now I have like
two priorities a day I'm like these are
the most important things these are
things that are making the most money
and you know doing the most productivity
and they take maybe like two hours and
then the rest of the day is like pretty
open and I do get all the little things
done without having to stress out about
them I like I start answering emails
like on a break like from Animal
Crossing when I've realized through this
is that I need things to look forward to
that's my biggest thing and so what I
realized about myself
over the past like through this is that
over the past couple years I have really
just created like an excuse for myself
to like for example with energy drink
quit where I don't get energy from
energy drinks me neither I don't I don't
I just am addicted to this ritual that
I've had since I used to do improv shows
were before I'm doing something that is
where I'm gonna be like you know like
really engaging with it I need to have
energy it's just a ritual training
exactly so I put but I've noticed that I
do that throughout the day right so I'll
I'll do I'll start my morning with an
energy drink say and then like maybe at
lunchtime or like a little bit after
that I'll have some other drink like
come Gatorade or something like sprite
zero or sunny whatever I mean not yeah I
do that but it's not fun
don't be silly G ho I know it's funny
it's funny but it's tied into what I'm
trying to so this it's hard because I'm
trying to communicate about how I know I
have a problem about this stuff mmm it's
tied into rewarding myself it's just a
habit right yeah it's just psychological
like even you know when they're talking
about cigarettes like it's a it's a more
powerful addiction with cigarettes it's
it's more it's supposed to be more
powerful than heroin and that's because
the accessibility in the psychology not
the effects of it heroin is actually
physically more addictive than nicotine
nicotine did go it gets out of your
system within 48 hours and within the
whole week it's completely out of your
system but
the reason why it's so addictive is
because of the years and years of
psychology and habit building it looks
so refreshing oh my god and you don't
think you when you when you smoke you're
not this isn't like as bad as heroin
you're not like right it's not as bad as
you don't feel it's a slow killer so now
that my weeks are not packed with like
different things going on I was able to
just go like wait why am I doing this
like it's like oh I do this to reward
myself I just do it to give myself a
little bit of dopamine like to give my
dad reflect on the things you do and why
you have them yeah why am i do I do I do
this I think I know this is going wait
what are you talking about but now you
get rewarded Animal Crossing oh no it's
not it's not even a bit or anything I
was trying to talk about my how I really
feel my feelings and actually talking
about psychology because I feel like
that's how I feel in Animal Crossing it
took over my busy tasks how I always
have to feel busy
well now I'm busy but an animal cross
see I'm building cliffs I'm Mick and
waterfalls
I'm hybrid crossbreeding roses but like
and so it fulfills that whole habit
thing that I was doing before in real
life without being stressful I think I
relate with the whole task thing right
because when I came back I feel like I'm
still be I'm actually busier now but I'm
more fulfilled yeah because I'm busy
doing things that I want to do even
though tasks and all these things it's
kind of like it all relates back to me
because they're my businesses and things
that's gonna help me grow eventually but
there's another selfish side of me
that's like I rather be just working out
maybe a little bit longer or maybe I
just want to go outside right now pick
some lemons without feeling any guilt
yeah you know and shoes yes yeah power
over your own life but at the same time
you know I feel like I'm lucky because
aside from my restaurants and stuff
right j/k and online jobs and things
like that we're not suffering like the
non-essential workers yeah like the
first thing is that we
let go everybody on the restaurant side
I felt horrible because it's like what
are they gonna do for work and but the
rest of the nation is this way but me
I'm like I I do still have this income
coming in which helps me where I can be
like alright now I want to be busy just
doing other [ __ ] and then I can focus on
growing yeah a skill set or whatever so
everyone that has that privilege they
can do that now but other people they're
just like what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
because that's the scary part if we
didn't have this but because of the
quarantine they're like having this much
time
it definitely has taught me a lot about
myself what I could do how lazy I was
before and show me how much free time I
have because before I felt busy by just
wasting time you know and doing stuff
that like going out or like gonna see
friends or like kicking staying a little
bit longer at the gym when I shouldn't
have or whatever maybe now I have so
much time damn like if I'm not using
this time properly I should actually
have to come out with something like
positive after this so it kind of like
balanced you a lot because if you're a
workaholic you added more chill time
yeah and if you're like too much play
you added more work time that's cool
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you